hello everyone you've seen how much
trouble everyone gave Bobby Fischer
during the 1959 candidates tournament
with the Carl Kahn so while I will be
returning to the 1959 candidates
tournament I decided to show one game
played 11 years after that tournament
this is the 1970 match USSR against the
rest of the world so the Soviets really
brought their entire army you know out
of the ten players that actually played
five of them were former world champions
and on board one was reigning world
champion Boris Spassky and aside from
those five players they had they had
time on of Korchnoi they had Paul Karras
you know a lot of extremely extremely
strong players you can imagine that
early on each time and David Bronstein
were only the reserves and this is a
game between Bobby Fischer and Tigran
Petrosian and in those day I mean in
those days in in that match Fischer was
actually playing board to board one was
bent Larsen as at that time but bent
Larsen claimed that he was stronger than
Fischer and that he would definitely
beat Fisher in if they ever played a
match but as you all know in their 1971
candidates match a Fischer kind kind of
annihilated Larsen with a result of six
to zero but okay and in this match
Larsen actually did pretty good on board
one I mean excellent he played the one
and a half to one and a half against
Boris Spassky reigning world champion
and the third game Larsen actually
defeated Spassky sauce possibly didn't
play game number four game game number
four was played by Leon each time and
Larson also beat Leon each time so he
actually had a great performance on
board one but this is the game I wanted
to show you Fisher versus Petrosyan as
Petrosyan once again employs the
caro-kann against Fischer but this time
it's it's not the 1959 Fischer this is
the 1970 Fischer
so Bobby goes for efore of course and we
have c6 d4 d5 at the Carrick on defense
and here we have the immediate it
captures on d5 the exchange variation
see captors on d5 and Bishop
III Knight to c6 c3 now defending the d4
pawn Knight to f6 and Bishop to f4 this
is called the Rubinstein variation of
the exchange caro-kann Bishop to g4 and
here what do you do here well there are
obviously a couple of options you could
go Knight f3 you could go Knight e 2 you
can move the Queen fish replace Queen to
b3 going after to b7 pawn Petrosyan
defense this would Knight to a5 we have
Queen to a4 check now Bishop to d7
attacking the Queen and Bishop Queen
back to c2 now it's very important to
see what Fisher did here one of the
tourism played this Bishop to g4 move
Fischer could have immediately played
Queen to c2 but if he immediately played
Queen to c2 as you can see Petrosyan
would have a nice bit of energy for he
would have a very nice knight on c6 but
if you look at the position that
actually happened in the game due to
Fisher playing Queen to b3 first then
you have disposition now there's a
bishop on b7 kind of blocking Patronus
development and also this night is
awkwardly placed on 85 so Fischer's
queen did and end up on c2 but
petrosian's pieces aren't so active east
6 we have Knight to f3 Queen to b6 now
and a4 now if you if you decide to do
something like Knight to b3 it doesn't
really hurt white as you can always go
rook to a2 and now the night doesn't
really have any purpose there so after a
4 we have ripped to c8 and now we have
night to d2 Fisher doesn't allow
Petrosyan to jam this Knight to c4
Knight back to c6 and now Queen to be
one Fischer doesn't want to allow well
the queen is and c2 any Knight captures
on d4 ideas maybe in the future we have
knife to h5 attacking the bishop Bishop
to e3 and h6 now Knight to e5 Knight to
f6 and h3 Bishop to d6 and we have
castles by Fischer and here petrosyan
could definitely Castle it's it's
definitely an option but he decides to
go King to s8f for by Fischer and Bishop
- eh now we have Bishop to f2 and now
Queen to c7 Bishop back to h4 and
ix to g89 to h5 probably was was a was
an idea that was a little bit better but
he decides to go night the g8 and here
Fischer goes for the immediate f5 and it
seems like an interesting idea of course
the king is stuck on f8 you know the
bishop is kind of blocking it on the
e-file then I just kind of blocking on
the G file so definitely you want to
open up a DF file as you have a nicely
placed rook on f1 and okay Petrosyan
goes for at night Knight captures on e5
will get D characters on e5 and Bishop
captures on e5 and of course F captures
on e6 so how do you defend here well
either you will allow white to capture
the f7 pawn followed by Bishop captures
or you might want to play f6 defending
like this in the game Petrosyan decided
to go for Bishop to f6 he captures on f7
Bishop captures on f7 and now Knight to
f3 developing tonight also defending the
bishop on h4 Bishop characters Knight
captures and now Knight to f6
we have Knight to g6 this Knight to f6
was a was a much-needed move as Knight
to g6 immediately would check the king
and for the rook as the bishop on f7 is
pinned so night to have six but Knight
to g6 either way Bishop captures Bishop
captures and we have King to e7 Bishop
to H sorry Queen to a5 now and we have
King to d8 so Petrosyan really tries to
do a nice King walk maybe at some point
he can even move the Queen and get his
king by c7 to be 8 but we'll see
rook rook 81 official develops his final
rook and now he's ready ready for some
action
Queen to c5 and this comes with check
came to h1 and now rook to f8 and here
we have Queen to e5 and you can already
see that there's a lot of pressure for
black in this position if the squee
never moves from this diagonal then
Queen to e7 will be checkmate so patrols
and plays rock to c7 to guard e7 square
one more time and perhaps he can get his
King to safety
via c8 and v8 but favor pushes before
now unfortunately you can't capture the
c3 pawn if you capture Queen is six
check and you lose the rook on f8 so
after before Queen to c6 but now comes
c4 and again you face the same problem
if Queen captures then Queen to d6 check
picks up the rock on f8 and if you play
something like rook to d7 to try and
avoid this then you get Queen to be a
check Queen to see eight and now Queen
captures on a seven and again what what
do you do here if Queen to c7 then you
simply capture the pawn and now if you
decide to capture it if you don't
capture it you really don't have a move
to play here you don't you can't move
the knight it's painted the rook on the
rope here is undefended you can never go
rock - eh - an open file so there really
aren't any moves black and play here if
you capture you get rook the c1 and it's
game over the Queen doesn't really have
anywhere to go you have to go Queen d7
but now comes Queen to b6 check and it's
game over King to e7
now comes rocky one and you're getting
checkmated whatever you do the king is
all all locked out you have to first
give up your your night with 94 then
you're up with rookie 5 and then finally
Queen e6 and this will leave the
checkmate so after this c4 move it's
really really hard to defend
Petrosyan petrosyan tried C D captures
on c4 but now comes Bishop to a5 first
preventing the King from escaping via c8
we have rook to f7 and here rook to d1
check rook F to d7 blocking and now
comes of course Bishop captures rook
captures and here Queen to be a check
King to e7 and now rook DT 1 and it was
in this position that Fischer that
Petrosyan resigned the game let me just
mention after this Queen to b8 move
Petros indeed go for King to e7 but if
you block it for example with Queen to
see it then you get rook captures on d7
Knight characters and now Queen to d6
the threat is rook to f8 checkmate as
the knight is pinned on d7 so if you
decide to go King e8 now we get we
sex check King moves back and now comes
rocket for going for the c4 pawn after
we play Queen to c6 try and do something
now comes Queen to g8 check and again if
you go to the C file with the king rook
captures on c4 you lose you lose the
Queen
so after King e7 not simply Queen
captures King moves and after another
check
you get rogue characters in c4 and you
can see that white is already a pawn of
the exchange so that's white can only
choose how to win this so like I said
after this Queen to be 80 check that
rose and went King e7 and after rook e1
he resigned the game because well the
King doesn't really have anywhere to go
the only square available for the king
is f7 if you play King f7 you get Queen
to d8 checkmate as the knight of course
is pinned on f6 and instead after rook
DT 1 if you block with Knight to e4 then
simply rook to a4 is sufficient to win
the game attacking the pin piece if you
defended route before then comes Queen
to f8 check King g6 and now Queen
captures and there are simply too many
threats here let's say your rook is
attacked on d4 rook to f6 check winning
the Queen as the knight is pinned on e4
so if you move the rook then again you
get rope to f7 and now there are again
too many threats here whatever black
plays and there's really not all that
much you can play let's say c3 now comes
rook check King moves and now rook
captures on e4 and again too many
threats this is just pointless but just
illustrate Queen here is checkmate Queen
here is checkmate so too many threats
after rogue d2 d1 Tigran Petrosian
resigned the game and this is a game
from round 1 out of the 10 players from
each team like I said the Soviets had 10
players and the rest of the world had 10
players every player played 4 games
against every other player so this was a
game from round 1 and out of the four
games Fischer played against Petrosyan
he won two games and two games were
drawn so 3 to 1 in favors favor and
interestingly he won one game with the
white pieces in one game with the black
pieces and this was the best result
out of the entire match Soviets versus
the rest of the world in 1970 the match
was played in in Belgrade and
interestingly yeah Bobby Fischer did
have the best score out of the entire
match but there was another player who
had three three points out of four games
and that was Paul Karras who faced
borislav Eve cook and he also had two
wins and two draws against Steve cook
but both both of Karin's were with the
white pieces so I very interesting match
and you know a lot of interesting games
were played I will put a link in the
description below where you can read
something more about this matter if
you're interested and I will put a list
of all the players that participated in
in this match and since you guys a lot
of photos so much I prepared a photo
here here you can see that's Fischer
playing against Petrosyan Fischer with
the white pieces that's that's actually
a photo from this tournament so I can't
really tell from the position on the
board is it actually this game but you
know officially had the white pieces in
two games so there's like 50% shot that
it's actually from this game i just
showed you know we can always pretend it
is just so we enjoy it more so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon